let's talk about what corporations oh
yeah yeah ladies and gentlemen um i
would like to warn you
uh if you have young children we're
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna ask everybody
to just try and use as much um
self-censorship and innuendo
to convey accurately what these ideas
are
and uh this is because it is adult
content we will not be uh getting into
explicitly
but it's a major news story
from fox news post mates slammed over
bottom friendly pride month menu the
post mates bottom friendly menu drew a
great deal of criticism on social media
from users who criticized the company's
pride month move
let me just simplify this for you
post mates
made a commercial
for what's called the bottom menu
how do i describe this with um now
without crossing into pg-13 or r-rated
territory we can't even be pg-13 because
this is a definitely a pg this is an
x-rated story
yeah what this means is that postmates
made a video
that was explaining how to engage in
adult gay activities
and was providing the service for it and
then went on to explain
why they were proud to do it
and they were you know
they said that they're tired of sex ed
being heterosexual or whatever and my
attitude was just like i don't see
commercials from like dole or del monte
about pineapples and like couples and
why that's beneficial or anything like
that i don't you know we don't have
these commercials
so this commercial was like a bit over
the top but this is the intent
so i don't think the story here
necessarily is the pride month thing the
story i see here is
we have gotten to the point where the
attempts to shock the public to get
attention have become so drastic and
desperate
they're actually just collapsing
decaying and falling apart
it used to be shocking content was
saying a naughty word or something oh i
can't believe they would say that now
it's
or remember when it was shocking to see
a man's butt on tv it was like nypd blue
candle right it was what was it dennis
franz yeah
yeah oh that was a brown scandal in the
late 90s
abc tv or something yeah i remember
because it also wasn't jimmy smith's it
was like really yeah come on he's the
cute one yeah come on man you couldn't
swear on tv yeah that's right now it's
just it's all kinds of crazy stuff so
what i see is this this ad
it was i mean this is like x-rated stuff
they're talking about it's kind of crazy
i was shocked when you showed me this i
hadn't uh i hadn't been online much
today and i thought that was enough i
took a look at this and i was just like
oh my goodness they're basically they're
basically explaining what's insane can
you pull up the ad yeah let's no i can't
you can't one of the fruits
of course i can't show it it's it's got
it it's show it shows like fruit peach
is walking around a peach at an eggplant
fetish but there's like right there's
like kink stuff in there yeah yeah yeah
so weird they did have one recently too
where it was like um
two buns that were both the top oh yeah
that's that's that's burger king yeah
that was the that was the tame version
of this burger
yeah so to me this is more of the
contagion of social media you have to
shock you have to make everyone engage
with what you're saying and it doesn't
matter if it's in the form of a ratio
and the quote to eats or if it's people
being positive about it in fact negative
attention is often more engaging for
people than positive attention because
it's just kind of how we're wired yeah
people are more likely to comment if
yeah if they have something negative to
say rather than something positive
it's commercial explaining the negative
ramifications of a bad diet while two
dudes do it there you go
yeah yeah and it's like here's what you
need to eat and here's why you need to
eat it and i'm like wow i never thought
i'd see that i mean what it's cool if
they're promoting fasting well as a gay
man here can i yeah what are my thoughts
uh i find this
offensive not because of
traditional or religious values but the
fact that
once upon a time much of the effort that
helped really to mainstream and
normalize
tolerance for
uh gay and lesbian people was factor
showing that we are just like you
and
now
these advertisement campaigns in recent
years and political campaigns and social
campaigns during pride are about
focusing on
like sex and explicitly sex and that's
i mean that was what originally made a
lot of people uncomfortable around
gay or lesbian people they always
thought about the sex and so fetish and
all that and then the fact you know that
this particular
advertising campaign is
focusing on
um anal sex and
using references to fetish gear to talk
about
what's that had to do with delivering
pride yeah no food delivery exactly
so someone responded to their tweet
and they said if you are not literally
helping us have sex are you really an
ally and postmates said exactly and
that's blah blah blah and they're like
that's what we want to do and
i'm like i didn't realize my food
delivery service was required to help me
have sex well the other thing too is in
a lot of ways pride has morphed into
something of of just being pro proud of
your sex kinks right cometh before the
fall we've seen that like so the
washington post ran a whole piece about
why it's really important to take your
kids to pride so that they can see kink
fatherly recently ran a piece
talking about how it's really important
to take your kids to pride and to
explain to them what kink is there's all
of these pushes from um like you know
people advocating for more sex ed saying
that you have to talk about kink as part
of sex ed
but they're not talking about healthy
relationships they're not talking about
love they're not talking about you know
goals for successful partnership or any
of that it's just all about like this is
how you get off and getting off is the
main point of life they'll they'll
explain it as a is love to encounter
because it's erotic love eros is a type
of
bailey um i think that a sect of
humanity in the last 15 years has become
extremely or decentralized or not
decentralized desensitized to sex like
big time the kids that saw porn when
they were nine ten years ago are 19 now
and they're kind of leading the charge
they're probably ceo postmates and then
there's a grand 19 year old maybe not
but soon and there's a grand percentage
of us that or people that are not
desensitized to it and are like freaked
out and are freaking out and those
people that are desensitized are having
fun with it
they see that it's getting reaction that
other people can't take it the puritans
oh my god and so they're just pushing it
and because like you can't stop me well
i'm a united states citizen and they're
pushing it on kids in order to justify
their adult fetishes i think that we
should use law enforcement for that kind
of thing yeah well some people are
trying because like if you did that in a
parking lot you had um in texas they
were working on trying to it's
similar but different trying to
criminalize the
medical gender transition of minors it's
weird because like if there's a
community that wants to do weird sex
stuff you kind of just let them do their
weird sex stuff but then this is the
live and let live thing this is kind of
you know to a certain extent i wonder
i'm just throwing this out there
is it possible that this is how we got
here
for me it is i've had hands off for 20
years i've been like do whatever you
want do whatever i've always said that
too like whatever anybody wants to do
that's up to them uh but perhaps yes
perhaps yes do whatever you want to do
that's up to you but maybe it makes
sense to discuss the perils of hedonism
you know maybe it makes sense to discuss
the the difficulties that can arise from
using your body as a sex toy
we have no choice at this point and the
psychological effects of watching online
this is all very real and it contributes
to the meaninglessness of our society
and it contributes to the nihilism that
is so much more easily grasped than
you know
any of any of the stuff that actually is
fulfilling but not only that but to the
destruction of future relationships
because if people are desensitized and
they're on the internet and their
parents just give them a computer or a
phone and then they're able to be in
their own room by themselves they you
know go on websites that rewire their
brains to prevent them from having
healthy relationships as adults um so
this is uh you know in my opinion a
larger plot of the depopulation agenda
this is one way to prevent people from
having children from having healthy
relationships because if we really did
care about you know this stuff we would
be talking about healthy relationships
boundaries way to communicate your wants
and needs ways to have a healthy
relationship ways to coexist with
another human being by being able to
respect them
as another human being and not see them
as an object so that would be something
that of course we could have a
conversation on but we don't all we have
is kink all we have is fetish all we
have is this weird stuff that you could
do because it's cool and trendy and this
corporation's telling you to do this
it's ridiculous it's it's so stupid i
think you're right that a lot of people
do this is a good opportunity an uh
example of us humanizing people that we
may not agree with and kids watch this
show which is a good thing
i have a working theory that they are
choosing the worst parts about these
lifestyles to make for example gay men
look terrible i think they're actively
taking steps it does make us look
terrible it does it looks terrible and
nobody wants to talk about the dark
parallel that runs with this super
encouragement of sexual promiscuity is
the dispos disproportionate rates of hiv
and sti infections in monkeybox
yeah i mean that's the story right now
yeah
well i think if you're going to talk
about the health effects that you need
to consider when you're living a high
risk lifestyle you should talk about all
of them you should talk about the
problems that come with promiscuity you
should talk about so i should talk about
the problems that come along with
being in really intensely dysfunctional
relationships but they're not they're
just trying to make a splash and
it's so shallow and short-lived and i
think it's seriously throwing our
culture off balance so i mean we've also
like so clearly destroyed families yeah
you know i've been giving this a lot of
thought um
just personally about like my own life
and my family history and everything uh
my grandparents on both sides on my
mom's and dad's sides were both divorced
in the 70s
my parents got divorced um
i think they got divorced shortly after
both their parents got divorced you know
they got divorced um
my
my dad got divorced twice after that my
mom got divorced again after that you
know
my husband and i split up like what is
this like we can't this is generations
at this point of people who cannot
maintain a family structure
um you know and everybody you ask them
everybody's got a really good reason you
know everyone's got great reasons why
they couldn't maintain their their
marriages why they couldn't maintain
their families um but literally every
single one
is messed up and then i look at what's
uh let's pull this story around and then
i look at my son and i'm like is how is
he going to be able to maintain a
marriage like how you know thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you